da sind keine jahr zwei stück punkte ich
laufe jetzt nur ich bin laufe ich bin
laufe ich schaltete aufkommen ich will
einfach nur punkte bringen klick dich
durch ein liebe freunde und herzlich
willkommen zurück zur mono braun mit
pommes pommes hd ja hallo hallo und
sommer hat letzte mal richtig abgeräumt
so dass das ist einfach so ein gewinner
ich bin ein gewinner und ich erinnere
mich erkennt die weihen
es gibt deswegen haben sie jetzt hab ich
vorsprung jetzt kann ich ein paar
schilder vorlesen ein
es gibt eine wichtige sache die ihr auf
jeden fall wenn ihr meinen erfolgen noch
nicht geschaut hab wissen solltet ich
habe vier punkte damit herrscht
gleichstand
wie viel bekommt jetzt insgesamt vier
okay ich hab auch hier ich dachte jetzt
hier gefunden nennt mord dass das war
heftig hätte ich hier viel stück
gefunden ich sag dir ich wäre
aufgestanden dann der partie gewesen
dann wäre ich dann gemacht aber er kann
auch unter und jetzt acht wer mir einen
checkpoint ist doch kein problem für uns
beide
nein für dich schon das ist so und weil
für dich und dann sind wir schon wieder
obenauf dort rosen in der
für mich ganz viele wassereimer jetzt
was hast du eigentlich noch alle tassen
die lacher alter war weil ich brauche
hier nicht doch nur ein zurück
tausende von diesen teilen mein gott
porsches instant 11
woher der abwaschen abwaschen
man kann so schlecht ich habe eine rose
gepflanzt und wie wenn man einen stack
oder auch kein steak im inventar liegen
harte weg oder einig und wenn man den
dann gehalten hält im winter kann man
den eigentlich so lang ziehen und
aufteilen
den kannst du gehalten dann kannst du
dir wenn du linke maustaste gedrückt
hält macht es gleich großen stadion bei
rechte maustaste lag sowohl einzeln
ehrlicher gratis aufgefallen kannst du
dir vermeiden meine 40 minuten
vorstellung zum 1.5 update schon und
jetzt bist du erst mal da unten ich
werde dich erst mal ins wasser reichen
elfer displays gedrückt dann wäre das
mit perfekte steilvorlage gewesen
und das macht spaß hier wo ich gerade
bin
das macht richtig spaß wollten mir das
okay ich dachte schon das schafft man ja
wohl punkte
nein noch nicht okay das ist jetzt zum
wasserfall
hallo liebes nein ja betten lächerlich
so ausrichten wir beide schlafen mal
okay ich glaube jetzt auch weiter
ich bin ok kommen ich bin schon so weit
ich laufe einfach ich auch weiter wie du
halten da um es den knopf ist getan
der glaube ich noch gar nicht ob wir
sollen hier so hin hier ist ja verstehen
geht das schon wieder los
irgendwann kommt immer der punkt wo man
einfach mal sagt ja jetzt braucht man
einfach wo wir meinten komm wir machen
frieden
das war noch in der ersten folge glaube
ich ne h
ok ich mich drüber nach dem aufbruch
geschafft
jawoll glückwunsch hauptsache ich
schaffe das nicht
mensch ich hab noch am boden bist du
jetzt ruhe
das sextett ruhig wollte ich eigentlich
hat auf raschen fünf punkte ich würde ja
ich spüre ich führe ich führe in your
face vivacon verein hier ist nicht in
meinem gesicht triple baumann er das
kann ich nur und immer noch ein problem
wasser dinge drin wie immer alle und ich
verliere gerade wir unter herrlich
herrlich das mache ich war grad wieder
runter herrlich
das ist natürlich wieder runter gefallen
stellen ich alles infrage was man hier
sagt doch wir sind wir leben im
zeitalter der aufklärung das heißt ihm
ist alles in frage stellen
bis alles hinterfragen jede sache die
euch gesagt auch den spruch demokrat
abgelassen
die müsse auch der frage ob dieser
sprüche gestimmt ob das wohl stimmt ich
weiß nicht was mich aufregt sind die
sprünge hier die die immer noch wasser
sprünge ich hoffe es ich hoffe es ist
schlimm dass wasser springen oder
lennart jumps ich glaube leider springen
obwohl die kann ich mittlerweile recht
gut was ursprünglich nicht wenig aber da
gibt es noch viel weiter höher
was haben wir hier wie ein checkpoint ok
oh gott wo muss man die kiste da
genommen die da am werk war
ja die habe ich da war der fünfte punkt
und ich hab s ich wollte darüber ein
spaß machen so nach dem motto ja ich hab
ein punkt gefunden hab ich bin schätze
echte tour herrlich oder ich schieße ich
will lieber nicht ab und wartet nicht
auf der aufnahme was ich warte aber
hallo
was genau so wie du später vorbei
ich wollte dir ja warum
warum kommst obwohl ich mach dich fertig
herrlich na gut selber schuld
wirklich nicht eingehalten ich da auch
nicht
ich habe ihn nicht geschlagen ich bin da
runter gefallen
okay man erkauft einführung ist kann ich
nicht wahr sein was richtig oder roter
schlagen da hattest du dich auch leben
mache ich genau so etwas noch getroffen
ich hasse leiter sprünge da habe ich ja
leute erstmal nicht weiter
ich glaube das habe ich schon einige
gehört in der regel gesagt mit dem loch
ich hab das doch getroffen
er arbeite ich auch immer in der regel
klick klick
ich drücke das wieder für die komik nein
da sind nur schneebälle den euro heute
war eine kiste komme ich zurück für dich
hier drückt ein paar jahre halten
jetzt drücke ich meine zeilen danke netz
zurück ich habe noch ein stück pizza
das bringt ihr gar nicht viel okay ich
halt gedrückt
123 123 ja nein das macht überhaupt
keinen spaß die sprünge
diese trap door sprünge obwohl die gehen
eigentlich das kann ich nicht sein
ich laufe und laufe und laufe und der
gomez schafft das wieder welcher die
ganze zeit darauf drückt ja ja 13 ich
habe sie gehofft
ich öffne das das was du es geschafft
ok dann fangen wir an
nein nein das ist das ja eigentlich
gewandelt
doch die war sehr nervig all das richtig
weit weg ich bin der oben kann die worte
ich bin hier oben haben es geschafft ihr
war hier waren wasserfall weißt du ach
so ich werde dich nicht ankomme hdt hab
ich geschrieben
ja das ist natürlich ist der strom
bleibt doch mal einfach kann da nicht
drauf warten erwarte ich warte auch hier
oben auf dich wo ok kannst ich komme
direkt mit spot läuft er wieder vor hier
scheiß ich mal hier auf gomez wartet man
die kiste aber da gehe ich jetzt nicht
hin
doch da geh ich wollte keine von blaze
runter geschlagen zwei stück punkte ich
glaube jetzt nur richtig enorm laufen
jetzt ich bin laufe ich scheiße drauf
komme es aber nur punkte bringen fick
dich fertig
als schlechter verlierer doch hast ja
nicht weil ich meine wir hatten drei
folgen was du für in führung
jetzt komme ich hier mal eine folge vor
12 folgen da bin ich mal in führung
jetzt hat man wo müssen hätte ich hin
will ich weiß nicht wo du gekommen bist
ja da
und was ist das auch in laval okay
ja da und geschafft man kann ja auch
springe ich nicht mehr natürlich ganz
schnell weiter her wie einige spannt du
bist ich bin richtig locker hier drauf
weist die fresse habe ich bin ein
gentleman ich bleibe immer locker und
ruhig und früher und natürlich höflich
nett mal big mac und egal was passiert
ich bewahre die pizza wieder lecker
lecker lecker haben wir im bett dann war
ich vorschlag dabei kaputt gemacht egal
dann kann man nirgendwo nacht machen
komme ich mache normal nachhaltig nach
oben natürlich nach gemacht so schön ich
bin schlafen gegangen gut immer mal hier
doppelt so viel regen mich angemacht ich
hab dir ausgemacht ehrlich ich hab den 1
warum du hast doch die aufgabe einfach
nur spaß
dann kommt ja ja ich war ja noch mal
doppelt an vorder und auch ich mache
gold genau aufeinander abgestimmt
die hatten wir im skript werden wir wie
immer ein skript in aller welt alles
grundsätzlich ab ja auch das m und das
sind die lacher oder denn damit das
ganze glaubwürdig erscheint ja steht
manchmal bestehe also manchmal auch
einfach nur an husten oder sondern halt
damit es auch so kommt normalversion
seriös bleiben sag mal was machen die
cryptbox baum die strohpuppen kommen wie
bist du darüber gekommen
ach ich bin da auch von zaun gesprungen
auf den song ich schon
diego ich aber das war's auch schon den
nächsten coup ich immer den schwierigen
stellen herr wirklich wir sind genau bei
15 minuten wieder stelle er ist ja egal
ob das jetzt grade bayern viertelstunde
ist aber es ist geschafft ja okay dann
bin ich mache das jetzt noch immer hier
zu ende
könnt ihr nein ganz knapp jetzt komme
ich nie war das hier noch und ich hab's
geschafft
direkt bei der sexy lady hier die mit
das ganze mit mir spielt ganz süße mops
und da ein krebs mittendrin
ok daumen hoch geben und schreibt alle
gamer game verändern ich frag mich mal
gucken wie lange die map noch in etwa
geht habe ich ja gut ich sag jetzt mal